the cliche question when someone writes
a book like this what was the one
trait that you saw across the board of
all these leaders was there anything
that stood out
yes um the great leaders they're really
great leaders are people that recognize
they had luck
because they had failed at something
they overcame it and as a result they
really
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy hey everybody it's gary
vaynerchuk
super excited to do a interview uh on
the podcast
as a lot of you know uh pretty
infrequent these days given the
global situation but leadership is
something that i uh
am very very passionate about and my uh
esteemed guest here david rubenstein who
i'm gonna let introduce himself
and create uh some context for you both
about his co-founding of the
iconic carlisle group but also the uh
the book that he's uh written
uh and i think we're gonna get into a
fun conversation so david welcome to the
show
my pleasure to be here thank you my
friend why don't you give the
vaynernation the audience here a little
context of uh your professional career
and then we'll uh maybe i'll bounce
around ask a couple questions and then
we'll go into the book
hey i was trained as a lawyer uh wasn't
that good at that so i got out of that
went to work at the white house where
president carter wasn't that good at
that so i got
i went back to practice law that didn't
work out so well either again
so i ultimately started a firm called
the carlyle group which became a large
private equity firm
and i ran that for some 30 years or so
and
now i am the largest shareholder of it
and the co-executive chair
but i spent a fair amount of my time on
philanthropy i was a
original signer of the giving pledge
that bill gates and warren buffett put
together
and i now am involved in essentially
giving away my money
i spent spend a lot of time on
nonprofits i am the chairman of the
kennedy center in washington
i've been the chairman of the
smithsonian institution i'm the chairman
of the council on foreign relations
i was the chairman of my alma mater duke
university i now spend a lot of time on
university boards i'm on the harvard
corporation the university of chicago
and johns hopkins medicine and i now
also uh
have a television show on bloomberg uh
called peer-to-peer conversations and
that led to a book
that i did on leadership where i took
people like bill gates jeff bezos warren
buffett
colin powell david petraeus and so forth
and asked them what it was
that led them to be leaders and i
distilled that in a book called how to
lead
which is now out and on the new york
times business bestseller list
so that's what i've been doing david
going back to your youth do you think
you went into law
uh because that was a good thing to do
according to your parents or society you
know what what
made you go down that path well my
parents were not college or high school
graduates so they didn't really have a
lot of uh
influence on what i would do because
they didn't have experience in that
but if you were jewish as i was and am
probably your parents would say why
don't you be a doctor or a lawyer or a
dentist
so i think that was very good in the
sciences i was afraid i'd get arthritis
in my fingers if i became a doctor
so i said i would be a lawyer and i was
probably better at talking than i was at
uh
things that would take me into the
medical world so i became a lawyer but i
also
thought that lawyers went into politics
politics was something i was interested
in
my real goal was to work in the white
house for a president and um
ultimately i did that i didn't have any
interest in making money i didn't care
about it i grew up
relatively without any money and so you
didn't have any money you didn't think
about it
when i was growing up there were no
billionaires in the united states and it
wasn't something people aspire to be
david when when you how old were you
when you were
invited to be part of the carter white
house i was 27 years old
uh well to uh much too young i was only
three years out of law school but i
became the deputy domestic policy
adviser to the president united states
so
when you're three years out of law
school and at that age you're going
around on air force one and marine one
and camp david
you know you can think you're pretty
good and people tell me i was very smart
and brilliant and all that
then when i looked for a job after we
lost the to ronald reagan in 1980 nobody
wanted to hire me because they didn't
want to have a
carter white house aid then so i had to
spend a couple months trying to find a
job and
i didn't want to tell my mother i was
unemployable so i just tell her i had so
many offers
i didn't know which one to take crippled
crippled by opportunity
right absolutely so many chances to take
the job i couldn't decide
and at 27 when you got
the word that you in essence
based on what i'm hearing from you
achieved
a goal of your youth was it
anti-climactic
was it remarkable was it
15 minutes of jubilation and then fear
like
how did that moment you know i think a
lot of people listening right now
will end up achieving i'm always
fascinated by
goal setting you know people go in very
different directions and some people
find themselves achieving certain goals
or the goal early on
how did that one play in your mind well
i was a junior white house aide the
deputy domestic policy advisor i thought
carter would be re-elected
and i would be the senior domestic
advisor and then after that for four
years
i would go out practice law come back as
a cabinet officer and eventually worked
my way up to be a senior
uh important government official i
didn't care about money so much so that
wasn't a big factor
uh unfortunately we ran against a man
named ronald reagan in 1980
and i said how can a man that old get
out of bed in the morning he's 69 years
old today he's
too young to run for president um and of
course i'm now 71 so 69 looks like a
teenager to me
but we didn't think we could possibly uh
lose to him and that's what happens when
you get
filled with um i would say uh cognitive
dissonance when you work in the white
house people tell you how great you are
and you don't listen to any bad news
because you think people don't really
know what they're talking about when
they write something bad about you
and that's maybe what we've seen in
other white houses today today at the
white house
and the current white house i suspect
most people think that the president's
going to win because
they just think he's wonderful i suspect
and uh and as a result
they are probably going to be surprised
i i guess i mean
do you like you know being in business
and and the cup
being the the iconic private equity firm
that you co-founded uh obviously
took in many many many businesses many
of which
at one point or another um were
extremely good businesses
which you know either led to the exact
reason that it
you know you went out and acquired or
the reverse
you know were great but then you know do
you feel
do you feel the delusion that probably
happens in every white house
republican and democrat over the last
hundreds of years
is a similarity to what you see in
businesses where
businesses oftentimes get so cocky at
the executive level
they're misunderstanding what's
happening at the consumer level and that
ultimately leads to their demise
well the president of the united states
and the people who work in the white
house are not unlike chief executives
people tend to tell them what they want
that they they expect they want to hear
so they don't hear the bad news secondly
when they read about bad news or they
hear about it
they think if only the people knew as
much as i know
they wouldn't say these bad things about
us and eventually they'll figure out
that actually i know more than them
but it doesn't really always work out
that way so in the business world when
you buy a company on day one it always
looks perfect or you wouldn't be buying
it but then eventually you realize you
may have made a mistake the world went
when it went
went against your thoughts about where
it was going and when the time comes to
make a change in the ceo you typically
waited too long
because you didn't believe things could
be as bad as they turned out to be and
the buyout world
probably 50 of the time you have to
replace the ceo who you once thought was
wonderful
and it just works out that way and
sometimes you can't anticipate things
for example
let's suppose you were an investor in
amc or
marriott or carnival cruise lines um you
would say these are great businesses
they're booming and then the pandemic
comes along
well who do you blame well you don't
blame yourself usually you blame
somebody else
i mean at that level david i'm sure you
know i'd love to get your perspective
that's why you're here that's one of the
true rare occurrences
where it's so macro so unbelievably
macro
that that become that that's one of
those rare moments
because i think accountability is
everything but those that is one of the
true rare moments
where you can chalk up a macro
circumstance or no
well you can you don't you don't blame
yourself as much for it uh you tend to
have a tendency to say well that's
somebody else made that mistake i'm just
going to try to make the best
i can of it but there are sometimes you
make mistakes you hire the ceo
and then you find out later he's a good
time ceo and the economy slows down he's
not a bad time ceo
yeah i think a ton about wartime and
peacetime generals
i think when you when you look at some
of the great ceos
she or he um get very exposed
in things like the great recessions or
times like this
well as it is said uh frequently
generals fight the last war
so if you're very good at fighting world
war ii you may not be so good at
fighting
korean war or the vietnam war or you're
very good in iraq you may not be so good
in
afghanistan so it just tends to be a
situation where you tend to know what
you know and you don't change very much
the great ceos and the great generals
are ones that have vision about what's
likely to happen in the future not what
happened in the past
and they respond to that and you see
that for example take the civil war
david i apologize for interrupting i
have a very interesting question because
i'm passionate about this subject
all right do you believe that
fortune 5000 i'm going to categorize
that way
ceos almost consistently
are in a place of such scrutiny now with
24-hour media
news cycles every 90 days accountability
quarter a quarter
that i i've been as you know i grew up
in entrepreneur land i
i became an early investor in facebook
and twitter and tumblr and
kind of rode that wave and then i
decided that i wanted to build the
greatest communications
infrastructure ironically um bleeds a
little bit into your world
i became very aware of 3g and i said you
know
i'm going to build the reverse of 3g i'm
building currently i'm building a
communications marketing media company
strictly to get into private equity
because i because i believe that
most private equity firms in the world
are good at
finding efficiencies when they buy a
company
and what i want to do is create hyper
consumer growth
around brands that i think have the
potential to be reformulated into
contemporary channels
and during that period of education over
the last 11 years
working with some of the biggest
companies in the world the ceos the cmos
board members and spending a lot of time
with
activist investors pe executives hedge
fund vcs
i am fascinated by this stunning high
percentage
that do no anticipation for actual
consumer behavior live in excel sheets
are math based on the back end and are
completely 90 day driven
because they care about their own
selfish short-term rois
which ultimately come to the demise of
the business thoughts
well obviously when jeff bezos was
building his company
and he took it public people made fun of
him in the in the analyst world because
they said you don't care about earnings
you have no earnings
and every quarter he would have more
revenue but they say there's no earnings
and he would laugh at them behind their
back because he knew he was building a
great brand
and at the end he had the last laugh so
the great entrepreneurs steve jobs bill
gates jeff bezos
mark zuckerberg they don't worry about
earnings per share per quarter
they worry about building the franchise
and eventually the earnings will come
people who they hire sometimes who've
been to bcg harvard business school
stanford business school
uh bain and so forth they tend to focus
much more on the more traditional things
worrying about
earnings on each quarter and earnings
revenue growth and so forth
but the people that are the superstars
of the business world
tend to do things that are different
than what you tend to learn at harvard
business school let's say
why is there not not that i'm asking the
uh typical fortune 5000 ceo
to become one of those individuals
my bigger question is why are they not
showing some level of tendencies that
look like that
i mean you know to me it's almost like a
hundred percent in the other direction
complete obsession in hitting numbers
in a 90-day window i mean i'm i'm
staggered by the lack of conversation of
modern
what the consumer's doing on podcasting
or what's happening with last mile
delivery or cloud kitchens or
there's just so many clear indicators of
disruption every day because the
internet
scale yet you know finding some costs
here
or making roi decisions on reports based
on a nielsen's
i mean there is some silliness out there
david well in the early days of a
company they tend to focus on growth
and as you know the out world is one
where you took an existing company and
try to make it somewhat more efficient
uh the growth capital world is
completely different as is the venture
capital world
so if you invest in growth capital you
tend to have entrepreneurs running those
companies much more
who are focused on growing the revenue
base and believe that the earnings will
eventually come
but david david what's the biggest
change in pe
from the day you co-founded carlyle
group to the current state of the market
well in the early days of private equity
it was basically 95
debt 5 equity sometimes 99 debt and 1
equity so they're highly levered
secondly the people doing the deals
tended to be former investment bankers
whose skill set was financial
engineering today
you have i mean 50 equity and 50 debt so
it's much
less leverage you tend to have more
people have operational experience who
are working in these companies
and therefore they know how to fix
companies a bit more than the former
investment banker types did
and also private equity is today seen as
mainstream not alternative
very few people do not have something in
their portfolio that is private
equity uh generally people uh avoided
that uh 20 30 years ago because they
thought it was too risky
people don't think it's that risky these
days no it's see you know in the world
of spax and vcs and this and that it
it seems to your point wildly
conservative by nature no
yes the private equity firms are often
considered the lessons
how does that run through your head like
do you laugh does that make you snicker
sometimes or
or giggle a little bit because you
realize you know back when you were
starting
there was a there was a a lot of
cynicism or curiosity of this volatile
concept
i've learned a lot from i have a
daughter that started a private equity
firm recently in the healthy food area
and she's teaching me how to raise money
in ways that i never knew about
and she's talking about the ways to
incite young
next generation investors and things i
didn't think about i used to introduce
her to my friends who might
invest with her i thought and well they
they said they don't understand what
she's talking about
but they say my daughter might and say
they turn her over to
their daughters and their daughters say
yes this is what we want so it's a
different generation the world
moves forward david i want some hot
takes almost like if we're on the espn
debate show of like
a little speed here around leadership
when i say leadership
what kind of goes in your mind what are
some of the words adjectives
things that run through your brain well
leadership is something that we need
because you can't have everybody be a
leader you have to have some people be
followers
and leadership is what moves the
business world forward and the
civilization forward the best leaders in
my view have
failed a bit in their career they've
overcome that
they have recognized that luck isn't
very important that they're not so
brilliant by themselves
they are people that know how to share
the credit they're people that know how
to
motivate people they're people that in
my view have some humility to them not
arrogance
they're people who have a high degree of
integrity and they're people that other
people really want to follow because
they're good role models
do you think patience is a play in there
well
entrepreneurs um tend to be less patient
than let's say
uh other kind of leaders if you're the
leader of a large company you may be
more patient
but you know too much do you think do
you do you think david you know it's
funny because when you talk about bezos
i actually think that was a i actually
find
that patience is that entrepreneurship
that the the speed and the and the and
the way it are viewed a lot of times
is the facade and the makeup that that a
lot when you kind of
wash that off if you look carefully
there's a lot of patience going on there
which
because you overlay patients you i think
it i think
patience as a framework actually allows
for
humility or for compassion and sympathy
and empathy which i think are also
required to be a great leader
any any thoughts when i say that because
it's something i've been really thinking
a lot about
well the people that often start
companies are driven people
high iq high work quotient and they have
to be patient with the people that
they've hired who are not quite as
driven as they are
and so if they just yell and scream at
these people all the time they won't
have all these people working for them
so they have a
patient they also have to be patient to
wait till the customers catch up with
what they're doing
because sales might take a while before
people realize what you've done is
reinvent part a part of the world so
yeah this is required uh to some extent
but
impatience is important as well because
if you're impatient you're determined to
get something done relatively quickly
you will motivate other people to work
harder
david one of the things you know i i i
i've been very proud
in my i'm 44 years old about to turn 45
i've
i i come from a you know similar
background as you i was born in this
in belarus in the former soviet union i
immigrated here in the late 70s
um and you know lived in a studio
apartment in queens
with my family my dad had a job as a
liquor store clerk and eventually owned
his own store and i
i kind of you know i'm a son of a
merchant more of a story of the 20s and
30s
eastern european jews than let's say
modern times because such a small group
of russian jews got out in the late 70s
i i've always you know thus why did i
tell you that because i started running
my dad's business at 22 years old
i took a three you know a 3.8 million a
year revenue business doing 10
gross profit and built it to a 65
million dollar business with no capital
not not raising not even a credit line
and i did that through innovation email
marketing.com
google adwords but i led people and i i
lead a thousand people today
i have a big platform where i where i
talk about
mindset and leadership and kindness i
recently in the last three to four years
it became obvious to me that my
obsession of kindness came at the lack
of candor
which created entitlement
when do leaders miss the mark and
actually create
entitlement instead of fake safe
environments
that can really flourish because that's
something that i've had to recalibrate
in the last 36 months and i'm in my
process and i view and i and i view that
my inability
to have candor led to entitlement
because i was taking on so much as a
quote-unquote leader
but it created delusion underneath me
well you tend to get people who surround
entrepreneurs who eventually tell them
what they think they want to hear that
often happens in the business world in
the political world
and so if you believe that everybody
who's it
you know it's david i apologize you know
it's funny
to me i i'm incapable of listening to
pro or con around me because
i only focus on what the consumer is
telling me
it was less about what they were making
me feel good and couldn't tell me what i
was doing wrong
it was more that i was incapable of
communicating
their shortcomings because of the
negativity that i felt surrounded it
i've only come to recently understanding
that candor is kindness
and i was curious as you've studied
leadership i do think
safety for your people underneath you
feeling safe
is an incredible infrastructure for
speed
which creates you know incredible
results both in sport and in business
and i was curious if you'd come across
um this subject or or how you view it
in the leadership scale of the fine line
between safety
or it becoming entitlement
well if you are working a business and
you build a business you want people to
think you're actually moving forward and
you're
reasonably safe in trying to take some
risks but if people are so nervous about
the future they can't focus on what
they're doing that's not good either
you have to walk a fine line between
scaring people who are working for you
and kind of motivating them motivating
them by a little bit of fear that if
they don't do a good job something bad
will happen
but they shouldn't worry about their
entire life falling apart if something
doesn't
work out well in the company so you have
to walk a fine line and not scare people
too much in the end you'll lose those
people because they'll quit
the the comp here for me is and and
you've had
you know uh an incredible career which
has created
a a an opportunity to probably
see a lot of families that
have means and i think the thing that
so many families that have means worry
about
is that next generation you know
especially when you come
you know especially if you're you know
you and i are part of the par the
the lineage that you know it's like i
say to a lot of my friends it's hard to
be hungry when you're always fed
you know and i think the the the comp
i'm making here is i think a lot of well
could you
families struggle with finding the
balance for their children
to create motivation and to create
reality because they live in cocoons
i think about that in the business world
as well sometimes in leaderships
thoughts jackie kennedy famously said
that if you mess up raising your
children nothing else in life matters
and the truth is in hindsight when you
grow up in a relatively modest
background
there's a big advantage you realize you
have to learn skills yourself and you're
going to make it on your own or you're
not going to make it
correct you get to be very wealthy and
you try to raise children it's very very
difficult
right i would say you know if you look
at the children of extremely wealthy
families
they tend to have some challenges nobody
in the forbes 400
was raised by somebody who was also in
the forbes 400.
if you're very very wealthy you're not
likely to produce a child who's also
going to be so hungry that he or she is
going to go out and make a couple
billion dollars it just doesn't happen
so that you just have to accept that so
in hindsight your
upbringing in my upbringing were big
advantages to us because if you have the
loving attention of your parents
and their willingness to support you
what more do you really need
if you're very very wealthy and you just
throw money at your kids they're not
likely to be that successful in my view
do you think there's comps there in the
way that people i mean i i feel like i
see that a lot with bonuses in the
corporate world
you know throwing money at the as the
carrot
or you you know i think a lot of times
people are too one-dimensional
in their uh leadership or inspiration
agree
yeah well sometimes uh you know you
people just measure their success
and accompany by what the size of their
compensation is
as opposed to other qualities they
should be developing that
are not often as measurable as uh
dollars and uh
sometimes people overpay people then and
the result is not what you want it's the
reverse of what you want
people get fat and happy and they think
they're great when they really should be
improving
the cliche question when someone writes
a book like this what was the one trait
that you saw across the board of all
these leaders was there anything that
stood out
yes um the great leaders they're really
great leaders are people that recognize
they had luck
because they had failed at something
they overcame it and as a result they're
really
humble if you sat down and had dinner
with warren buffett
you would have no idea that he's the
greatest investor of all time
or that he's worth the 100 billion
dollars it just you wouldn't see that or
if you sat down with jeff bezos
jeff bezos is you know very approachable
in the history of the world
the wealthiest men in the world
throughout history been very isolated
and didn't have great sense of humor you
know howard hughes wasn't a barrel of
laughs
uh pete or getty you know wasn't exactly
a person who was
you know hanging out with a lot of other
people but jeff bezos is very accessible
as is bill gates relative to
people have been the richest worker
people in the world in the past so i do
think that humility
is an important thing now you can have
great leaders who are not humble
you know i suspect that napoleon wasn't
really humble i suspect alexander grey
to attach the name great to himself
probably wasn't humble but generally the
people i admire the most the ones i've
written about have a fair amount of
humility
david i love you for saying that i'm a
big fan of that i i just don't
understand
how humans decide just because of their
wealth creation talent which is often
god-given that
that all of a sudden they need to impose
that
and are unable to calibrate balancing it
with humility i just don't understand it
arrogance is something that i don't
really uh value that much and i see it
from time to time and
you can judge a lot of people's flaws by
how arrogant they are
david do you think that people struggle
with um
watching someone and not realizing the
difference between
actually just being passionate and
confident and being
arrogant and lacking humility because i
find that to be the case quite a bit
well you can be passionate about
something without bragging about how
great you
are you can say your company is very
good without saying you are great
i think a lot of people give credit to
other people ronald reagan famously said
there's no limit to what humans can
accomplish
if they're willing to share the credit
and if people are willing to share the
credit i think it's a great
uh uh great thing and if you make a
mistake take the blame
we learned that that you know david it's
funny
that part i think a lot about
i think the difference between the
the balance between sharing the
accolades
and the difference between being
accountable
i find leaders struggle with
all the way accountability you know like
i said to a buddy of mine
i said yeah but you hired that person
well john kennedy made a famous speech
after the bay of pigs in which he said
i made a mistake it's my fault and his
popularity went up and people were
surprised how can you make such a big
mistake and your popularity went up is
because of inability
right he said it was his fault now what
we've learned is that politicians now
say i was my fault for one second and
then they say it really wasn't my fault
right but yeah in the in this last
minute and i really enjoy this couple
things the book is available on amazon
and all
platforms can you please give it a name
one more time because i have a funny
feeling a lot of people listening are
gonna buy it
how to lead how kept it you kept it
simple how is that still available david
well i don't know if they said it was
how to lead
david how competitive were you for this
book to do well
i think people will find this
interesting you have all the these
successes
right obviously you know but here comes
the book it's a week out
how much is it running through your head
of like i i want this
i want this book to sell i want this to
do well i don't need my buddy
you know who selling more books or i
want to be on this list or like how much
did your competitive juices get going
well of course if you work on a book for
a couple of years you want it to do well
i'm giving all the money away to the uh
children's yes it's not clearly it's not
a
financial value that's what i mean it's
not about the dollars it's the
competitive spirit that you don't want
one of your buddies you know hitting you
up saying they sold more copies and or
the passion to get it out in the world
in red and or just your own internal
like
you like games and you want it to be
successful everybody wants to be
successful in what they do and so i
wanted to be successful i want people to
read it and i hope young people read it
so they can be inspired
to be leaders themselves dave what's the
most interesting thing
of from your perspective of the young
generation right now
you know you you're in a fortune place
of living a full life at this point
if i said to you hot take gen z under 30
your observation what's most intriguing
to you i wouldn't say
your favorite thing i wouldn't say the
thing that they're missing i mean
intriguing to you i think the
younger people to a greater extent than
my generation are interested in
changing the world for the better doing
things that are healthier for the world
they're less focused on just making
large sums of money they really want to
help other people
and they want to be more connected to
the whole world not just their own
little neighborhood or country
david one last little selfish question
because i'm so passionate about
marketing communication i think when the
investment world realizes
how the fortune 500s are wasting money
on television and other
and even internet and just there's a
you'd be
flabbergasted i have a feeling based on
your background on
how poorly marketing media is spent in
the fortune 500 land
is that even on your radar is there is
there in your circles
in your radars is there an understanding
right now
that marketing is changing dramatically
and the coca-colas and the bmws and
the marriotts of the world are are in a
real chasm like a real real chasm
well let's put it this way if i was
doing this book tour
20 years ago i'd be on television and
radio
now i'm spending most of my time with
people who do podcasts
because people are listening to podcasts
and my children say dad you're not on
this podcast you should be on that
podcast
and so more and more people are
marketing things differently because
podcasts and other social media are the
way to go
clearly you understand that for yourself
do you believe in the investment world
in the in madison avenue in wall street
that there's an
understanding of this massive gap and
enormity of wasted
marketing dollars that could be driving
much bigger business results for the
biggest companies in the world or do you
think that conversation
hasn't bubbled up yet into the top 500
people happening but it's moving
more slowly much more slowly for example
when facebook
went public a number of years ago maybe
eight or nine years ago people said
well facebook's good but you're not
really on mobile devices and they said
well jeez why is that so important
eventually uh facebook figured out how
to be on mobile devices but until then
they were really getting caught
and behind so today you've got to be a
mobile device or social media devices
and it's a completely different world
david i appreciate your time i wish you
success with the book i hope everybody
who's listening picks up a copy take
care david
all right bye bye youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon